two off the rails
that's all i need to be that needs to be
said here today
uh come on the boys are back
thank you you guys want to see something
right off the bat
wait sorry but hold up
oh oh christ that is like
a bruised fruit right there my dude
that's dedication
brutal it actually looks a lot better or
worse i don't know do you think it looks
worse all like bruised
it's evolving right it's looking worse
in some ways better
here this is a image from this is from
the sketch we did last week where i
fell off the chair and it didn't this
was the same night so that's like when i
got home a few hours later and it was
already like
you know but this was from the sketch
where
i was messing everything up and i fell
off the chair that zach was building
and i landed right on the uh hard metal
part of the chair
with my full weight of my big fat body
and uh that was probably the most
painful thing i felt and
i can last i remember so but i'm i'm
glad that i wasn't just being a baby and
i actually have
the evidence that it was painful you
were a trooper about that
thank you zach thank you so much thank
you thank you well we got a great
episode here today
sponsored by liquid iv oh man we've got
a good app
it's always good when we're off the
rails
that now that's a good
now that was a train crash yes it was
fantastic um first of all
important before we get to anything
ringo starr's
birthday this is a serious message with
peace and love peace and love you know
love peace and love we love ringo and if
you don't know on his birthday he does a
call today july 7th at 12 o'clock
noon every day for everyone around the
world
just to do a chant of peace and love
peace and love
and that's today so here is his birthday
request for all of you
love that love that movie makers love
peace and love this
is just a gentle peace and love reminder
that on july the 7th
my birthday all i ask for is that at
noon
wherever you are in the world you just
go
peace and love peace and love
and that will make my heart sing all i
ask for for my birthday is that every
living human being on the earth
take a moment to recognize me he is
ringo starr to be honest so i'm not
going to hate on that but peace and love
of course
thank you yeah and i'm putting it on all
these channels now
because you know we're going to do the
big one in l.a
well there's a big one it'll be 8
o'clock at night
in england it'll be nine ten o'clock in
europe
and so i'm trying to get everybody
lined up peace and love
peace and love at noon on the 7th
of july a little piece of love a little
education and time zones as well very
interesting
so anyway you know obviously you know
how i care about ringo and i love the
beatles
and so we what we've managed to do here
today is um
well we prepared uh uh our we did our
own peace and love at exactly 12 o'clock
as he requested
um here's his is this his tweet oh this
is his tweet from this year
peace and love everybody 77 21 peace and
love time at noon peace and love come on
now everybody it's in love
peace you gotta love the guy who's like
i mean he's got to be over 70 pushing 80
by now right and
yeah for sure he's 81. yeah he's i think
he's is he turning
84 you're turning 82. dude he looks
phenomenal he is youthful
and i think it's all that peace and love
maybe the peace and love is the secret
to longevity
and billions of dollars he just turned
81
today damn he looks in good shape god
bless that man
thank you thank you well anyway um
why don't you go ahead and roll our 12
o'clock peace and love in honor of ringo
starr's birthday
this is a serious message to everybody
watching
my update right now peace and love
peace and love i want to tell you
please after the 20th of october
no
i'm warning you with peace and love i
have too much to do
there's no more fan mail and no objects
to be
signed nothing anyway peace and love
peace and love
of course thank you yeah great job
everybody
ringo's going to love that one of course
thank you thank you thank you
of course homage uh paying homage to the
great great
uh ringo starr piece of love video and
um
i mean what better way to honor the man
peace and love
peace and love so i hope all of you guys
do the peace of life i mean i
are we are they allowed to do it late no
does that count
no yeah and not i don't think so either
actually
i'm well yeah
it sounds like ringo starr has a peace
and love party like he has a big event
well i believe that video that we
watched it was from 2015
which i think was his uh
75th birthday and he had a extravaganza
that he threw
uh at his peace and love event they
probably all get together at 12
exactly and just peace and love peace
and love that's it that's all they do
that's all they do and it works because
the world is full of peace and love
it's worked it's definitely evident by
everything
it needs no explaining it's clearly
working well you know you make a joke
but it could be way worse
ah that's true we don't know the but
four but for ringo's peace and love
mantra
there's a there's a parallel universe
where people are not saying peace and
love at 12 o'clock
and it's way far away borrower is the
only thing keeping this
world together
um you know
so also by the way you guys know we
talked about trailer who's suing me or
specifically ryan kavanaugh
he's one of the owners majority owners
of triller
uh this is the article that variety
published about him
you can see it says variety here it's
kind of like a
it's a there's a time stamp here it's
kind of hard to see it or like how would
you call it watermark watermark
yes variety but anyway it says ryan
kavanagh
accused by ex-partner of running a ponzi
scheme so
in opening quarter my things flipped oh
yeah that was noah back uh
complaining that trailer doesn't work
it's so awkward
this of course is the one star review i
i left on on on
trailers uh on the uh you know
right their app which is just horrible
especially knowing about this guy
but even you know it's really a review
of the app but anyway you know i wanted
to read some more
uh trailer reviews just to
you know listen as an influencer as
someone who
uh is a social media star
i mean i can say that yeah millions of
subscribers one of the biggest
one of the biggest absolutely and most
influential
most respected for sure first in our
hearts
first and eight and first and well
absolutely that counts off the
charts listen i can say that i'm a
professional social media person
and i'm interested in the happenings of
these social
media pages so sure
[Music]
so you know i am going to read some more
trailer reviews just as we get started
with this episode
first one you know they say kevin hart
we read their
the product description and they
specifically say
that kevin hart is on their app yet we
saw last week that he is not on their
app
he does not appear to have an account on
their app of any of any kind
and people picked up on that one person
said false advertising one star kevin
hart doesn't have a trailer account now
what if kevin hart just has like a sock
puppet account like a low-key one
like he's i don't think that counts
because they're literally their thing
says join huge mega stars like kevin
hart
right i was like where's kevin hart
trailer right he's not on trip he's not
there well you would still technically
be joining him on the app even if he was
uh close i don't know that he has an
account then right
you're saying he just casually yeah he's
got like a generic uh little
profile picture and a username unrelated
to it that's possible
it's possible i just want to make sure
that we you know so let's let's amend
oh it's so awkward kevin hart
may be casually using triller although
based on the feedback probably not i
don't know who would even know beck
who's being paid
to post on triller had this to say yo
triller my thing's flipped thank you
zach
so kevin hart does not have a public uh
trailer account false advertising one
star
which i think is a fair rating you know
one star
based off of uh being unable to find
kevin hart well if you're a huge
if you're a huge kevin hart fan right
and it's being presented as a selling
point i was like
one star easy where's kevin hart no
uh someone said i would call that uh
false advertising
i don't know what that's in reference
still that's not fraud
i download this app to see one of my
favorite comedians kevin hart as
stroller
advertised to use this platform after
waiting four hours for the results to
load oh so they're also saying the app
loads really slow
i was very disappointed to find that
heart no longer has an account here
see that's one star let's think of how
to dig ourselves out of this [ __ ]
so ryan cavanaugh who this ryan
cavanaugh
the one that variety published an
article about accused
zoom in there yeah his partner
accused him of uh running a ponzi scheme
in in open court
even yeah and and by the way the same
one that bankrupted his previous company
um
what was it called um i believe it's
called relativity media
immediately and you bankrupted the [ __ ]
out i mean i'm only tangentially
familiar with his whole situation so
well we're going to get into the
bankruptcy documents soon big massive
dumps we'll get into that but anyway
this is the guy
suing me for exercising my first
amendment free speech right
but anyway back to his app trailer
false advertising oh man another false
advertising one star i downloaded the
app to connect with stars like kevin
hart
but he's not even there ceo ryan
cavanaugh was allegedly involved in a
ponzi scheme prior to running trailers
so not surprised the app description is
misleading
right that makes sense because
allegedly if it's true what his
ex-business partner said about him
running a ponzi scheme it would mean
that he was comfortable
deceiving people that's not fraud
well ponzi i don't know the details so i
can't specifically say if it's fraud or
not
but i will say it's false advertising to
say kevin hart is on the app when he's
not
false advertising one star
man people are not happy that kevin hart
does not have an account i mean one star
we want kevin hart
and i was saying ryan kavanagh you need
to get you need to fix
i would recommend editing
the description of the triller app to
remove big stars like kevin hart because
he does not have an account
well that we know what does that say
like go back to those front
what does that say uh ryan kavanaugh
accused by ex-partner of running a ponzi
scheme
right that was the variety headline
trying to think but nothing happens
i am seeing an article that there was a
press release where kevin hart did some
videos for triller but
the linked videos aren't there anymore
so videos aren't available
that's that's interesting because i
think that means that kevin prop they
probably wouldn't pay him enough so he's
like [ __ ] you i'm deleting my [ __ ]
he's out i'm guessing obviously i don't
know yeah we have no all i know is that
he
they have in his description kevin hart
no kevin art
correct very strange very strange
cringe app dan uh you can kill the music
zack
we don't need that on repeat thank you
cringe app i came to chiller for david
dobrik's content
since he had just slick cool promotion
for set up flick stuff cool stuff
once i realized once i realized that
david only posted twice i quickly
understood that i wasn't going to be
able to watch any videos of his friends
being assaulted on sadly
i mean come on guys why advertise a
diverse category of creators without
being able to live up to the promise
corporate america is known for its
honesty one star
right because david dobrik promoted
trailer but he only has two videos
meanwhile he's still
posting two and from what i understand
two videos and zero assaults
right that's false advertising that's
false advertisement but like if you go
to
tick tock and follow david dobrik there
there's plenty of new content every day
lower uh lower quality and comparison
i've downloaded this app and found its i
uh
ui engagement video quality algos and
everything
closer to quibby oh then tick tock now
that's a low blow
everything except everything seems
second rate one star
just watching my algorithms get crushed
yeah chillers should pay my medical
expenses oh boy
i first tried my i've tried filming my
first video on trailer and got so
frustrated trying to figure out the
glitchy interface i was convinced
i had pulled a butt muscle i went to the
doctor a few days later because the
excruciating pain didn't subside
it turned out i gave myself a hemorrhoid
from the stress
that's a one star experience how am i
supposed to do my job
as a school bus driver if i can't sit
anywhere all i wanted to do was film a
collab with kevin hart and he's not even
on the app anymore
now i'm on unpaid sick leave unable to
poop and i and i have no kevin hart
since i have plenty of time on my hands
i looked into the ceo of trailer ryan
cavanaugh who i mistook for harvey
weinstein at first see i'm not the only
i think that he does
look like harvey weinstein there's at
least one person out there who agrees
we'll show the picture ryan kavanagh i
see the resemblance
i do see there's still there's something
i don't see it
i don't see it anyway they go on he's
he apparently he's bankrupted his
previous companies and was accused of
creating a ponzi scheme by his previous
business partner
how does he have investors are they just
20 something trust fund babies it could
be
this one app this one star app gave me
one star hemorrhoid and i think ryan
personally owes me a payout for my
medical
expenses that's an interesting one yeah
do we have any good reviews okay yeah i
i want to be balanced here as possible
yeah let's get a fair shake of um i love
it i love it so much for the pop
and it just says bts so
bts that's that seems like a great
review so
i don't know what that means but this
person loved it
wasn't there another five-star one that
we felt like there was one just above
that oh this one yeah
all right this this so this is kind of
like if you're looking for a
good five-star feedback here it is uh
this app is very useful for those
person whose video are available library
and gallery
the person who have no video and song in
gallery
those persons cannot use of this app
right so a fantastic five-star review so
wait i'm just trying to weigh all trying
to be fair and balanced
right i mean you can listen to that guy
five stars one stars form your own
opinion
right trailer my thing is flipped one
star
they responded sorry sorry hey sorry for
the
oh it's experience awkward
and that's the guy they paid noah no
back huh
i tried using this app one star it only
works five percent of the time
that doesn't seem like a lot yeah
so um anyway i'll be checking in on the
trailer reviews
yeah you know give your genuine
experience of the app if it's one star
give it a one star if it's more than one
star give it more than one star but just
be
just talk about your experience you know
be truthful
and we will um we will be back there
every episode i mean
to review the reviews i'm just
fascinated by triller
who's suing me the owner ryan cavanaugh
suing me
right here variety variety published
this article about him
you know what's funny about this article
oh here's the watermark i was looking
for it variety
variety magazine famous wrote this
article
about it's really hard i feel like i'm a
trailer right now with all the
with the various mirrors it's all
flipped yeah
about this guy okay uh there's actually
one more review at the very bottom that
uh i think will lead us into our next
segment very
nicely okay okay okay
um can you highlight it because i don't
see that [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay no it's just the last one in the
gallery that you were just oh the last
one that got you got it
so uh we have one more apparently let's
go all the way down the bottom
oh not that far ethan um oh there's
another one star
okay a lot of people not having a good
experience here
excited i was excited to try this app
out
downloaded it and signed up for an
account the first video that appeared
when opening the app had a song
fortune sun by clear clear credence
clearwater
revival oh [ __ ] that's the band that you
that's the cursed band isn't it zach
yes it is clarence clarence clean water
clarence clements clarence clean water
uh
reborn thank god you can't say it
i'm so grateful i couldn't believe that
this app would allow this i tried to
turn it off but it wasn't fast enough
within minutes the doctor called and
told me i had penile cancer and my
postmates forgot my dipping sauce
from my chicken mcnuggets i cannot
believe ryan cavanaugh would back this
app
that is obviously not a real review yeah
i think that might have been a troll and
uh that's a troll that must have
been somebody who watches the show going
in and just leaving a troll review
i don't know man do not do that don't do
that okay
just to be clear we do not condone
and we do not encourage troll reviews
like this one here
this is totally unacceptable you guys
this is a serious message
yeah the football is in love the foot
soldiers would never brigade uh a
website
on command of their uh there's no
precedent of that
no president at all for the foot
soldiers and
i don't how did we get that name again i
don't really recall where foot soldier
came from
any wiki feature it's zach
[Laughter]
thanks zach what you should you should
be the fact checker
what did i do nothing he was making
sure that we don't brigade stuff oh
i'm sorry is that because the question
is
right over my head okay it's true we
have brigaded wikifeet but that was a
joke
we would i'm telling you guys now in all
seriousness do not leave
reviews like this is just unacceptable
okay
peace and love only serious reviews
serious reviews try the app
see how it goes and give it one star or
more
right one or more stars
some amount of stars between give
trailer star
download a trailer up to maybe five
stars give it download triller
and rate it one star or more or more
yeah depending on your experience
that's what i did right you tried out
the app
and you rated it one star beca based on
my experience right
all right so anyway speaking of the
curse
um there's been a lot of debate in the
office about the
credence clean water reborn
um the band that zach says every time he
hears the name
or the song something terrible happens
there's been a debate
i think a b for example is starting to
believe that the curse is real
uh you want to comment on that uh
it may be i mean the first time we
talked about on the show i had some bad
luck after but
like what happened um
i think it's too hot for tv oh
definitely
i don't know what it is uh he broke his
dick i
my dick is his dick just like snapped
jesus i've been thinking limp for like
eight months
wow you really can't have kids anymore
can you you can't have kids you just
gotta
yeah there's there's from his sack
you're already here for
first folks abs dick okay something some
terrible luck before
the the failure and you think it was the
result of the song
it's just a weird coincidence but then
again there's no such thing as
coincidence so i don't know
this is where i'm just my head spinning
i can't are you joking are you
not i'm being 100 serious yeah it was
really that bad huh
yeah well one thing was this was uh
prior to the david dobrik episode
oh my favorite well okay okay i see what
you're referring to
yeah that wasn't really luck let's just
let's just let's just say it i mean
listen you uh
go ahead go ahead well let's just give
context what you're saying because
you're looking back on your life and
you're
re-evaluating something let's just say
something happened where you got stirred
into a controversy
it blew over everybody loves a b there
was a there was a controversy
yeah based on you defending david let's
just say that me defending david correct
and um how soon after the song was
brought up
did that happen because zach says it has
to happen within 48 hour window
depends on the person oh stop you said
48 hour window changing the rule
i think it was the week after the week
after we need go
like it's not like oh i listen to clean
and clean clean water
yeah and then a year later something bad
happens they're classic rock
things happen bad people all the time
it's not an obscure band the
classic rock radio staple like every day
everything
around the world all around the world
their music is being played all the time
this doesn't make sense how does the
world function if we're all being cursed
and there's no expiration date okay look
what happened to your leg though
it start it started on that friday the
friday we talked about it actually
but i just yeah i don't want to go into
that on the show but it did start that
friday
leading into the next so why do you
think that was a result of the curse i'm
not saying it is i'm just saying
it is well did something did something
bad happen to anyone after us talking
about it on the last
episode no we'll see stan
i came in on monday i was like how was
everybody's weekend i
i didn't give it away i was just like
how's every weekend everybody have a
good weekend i check with everybody
without bringing it up and everybody
including zach was like yeah it was a
good weekend fourth of july
dan was i was like i was probing because
i wanted to see
if you know i just left it ambiguous
what i was asking about if anybody was
like oh yeah i got into a car wreck this
weekend or whatever
nothing happened everybody had a great
weekend dude i even played the song zach
like come on you got to give it up you
just gotta believe
no one why do you want to believe that
yeah gotta believe it man
why do why would i want to believe that
just happens man
she's got to believe oh god i hope your
dick breaks
wow that that's real [ __ ] nice dan
i quit my job
yeah nobody around the world's ever
heard that song
he's gone i just find it funny how like
the meme is like uh people
from vietnam soldiers they associate
that with ptsd i wonder what they would
think of
zach freaking out from it hmm yeah he
never even served it nom
i mean this did happen when did i get
this this bruise it was before the show
which we hadn't yet talked about so zach
and then that's the things that goes
oh it could happen it could happen in
the future
right he thinks it works retroactively
dude this is really bad like it itches
look [ __ ]
believe what you want to believe did you
get back so fast you like ran out
believe what you want to believe [ __ ]
has happened to me
and i just want to express that has
anything bad
ever happened to you when you hadn't
heard ccr
well i mean have you has anything bad in
your life ever happened
i'm just saying the perspective of mcr
well of course that that'd be perfect
it didn't but you can't compare that
that's apples and oranges okay okay okay
did anyone else have anything bad happen
to them just speak speaking
a great [ __ ] weekend it was awesome
my weekend was fine yeah
was honestly fine okay
abe you got something who almost got had
in a car crash did we talk about that
last week it was damn well that was what
sparked the whole conversation right
yeah but cameron sam no problems
ian no problem guys right all good
they're
they're saying love no issues love nope
nothing
dude this curse is [ __ ] bro i'm just
you gotta
i'm not dropping it it's my belief this
is religious persecution
yeah what's the name of the religion uh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] off no it's it's it's religious
persecution
of what religion it's bad luck it's it's
what's the name of that i don't know
again i
i know my constitutional rights here
okay all right
zach my the repair guy was supposed to
come to our apartment on saturday and he
didn't end up showing up so i mean lena
stayed home all day does that count
there you because you were waiting for
that you would you left early
one day tragedy that's what i'm saying
exactly i think your engagement
tragedy is a little i think every day of
zack's life is a tragedy and
yeah that that's a pain that's hurtful
every kid in the veil every kid from the
valley is cursed i'm from the valley
are you having a great life dude i'm
just killing it i'm sorry
sell the belly all right i'm just i'm
fair warning you guys
i'm just fair warning you guys i don't
know what more i can do i've played the
song i've said the name i mean at this
point a [ __ ]
lightning better just strike it down and
kill me
clear clearance clearance maybe that
clearance clean water you can't even
the fact that you can't say it might
serve as a bulwark to the curse
offending you okay all right enough with
the curse let's move on
yeah actually uh we're almost at 30 so
it might be time to just throw there was
interesting feedback i don't know if you
guys saw in the audience with people
saying they believed in the curse or
they had their own curse yeah yeah peop
i've gotten messages people think zack's
hot
people think zach's hot that's it that's
not here nor there i'm just saying that
i wish people thought i was hot ever in
my life
i think you're hot yeah thanks
you're not my type
really i wish i talked into the mic like
zach
okay you know what let's throw to a
quick break and then when we come back
let's get right into it
stay tuned time to take a short break
liquid iv we love liquid iv
here at the h3 podcast here it is
you get these packs this thing is going
to change
at all this one i've got here is the
hydration multiplier
tangerine flavor immune system
extra liquidy
uh hydration everybody back there's been
slamming the uh
liquid ivs isn't that right that's true
dan loves it
i love it as well abey didn't you say
you were slamming it with lena
yeah so you get it like this
you just put it in water i'm gonna shake
it up this is what it does
it's good for yoga working out
meditation it's a hot summer we gotta
stay hydrated people
when you're first waking up they've got
a caffeine boost after workout
uh if you're trying to hydrate they've
got one for that they've got one for
like if you wanna immune boost then what
i love about liquid iv is that first of
all
besides tasting great
and hydrating the living frick out of me
they've donated 11 million sticks to
people around the world
cheers
[Music]
i feel the hydration coursing through my
veins
[Music]
they got flavors like lemon lime acai
berry passion fruit guava watermelon
apple pine strawberry
it's got five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange and as much
potassium as a banana
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and less sugar than
apple it's made with clean ingredients
non-gmo vegan and free of gluten dairy
and soy
don't be a soy boy drink liquid iv
not their coffee the thing is it's got
that optimal ratio of glucose sodium
potassium that delivers water
and nutrients straight into the
bloodstream it's a perfect balance to
help you hydrate more quickly and
effective than water alone
[Music]
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently
than water alone love these mothers
so good grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com
and use the code h3 at checkout that's
25 percent off
anything you order when you get better
and get better hydration today by using
the code
h3 at liquidity.com
cheers
[Music]
we are back from the break thank you for
watching thank you for staying
we got some great stories here
basically both of their main stories are
about how
uh the internet is the absolute i mean
all of our stories really
are just horrible uh they're just
horrible
in reality you guys got scammed right
right i mean let's start with
there was prob maybe the biggest scam
in hit in youtube history the most
brazen at least
i don't know austin mcbroom kind of
holds the trophy for the biggest scammer
but
he's still racking him up too right but
this save the kids token i don't know if
you guys have heard about this
was pretty bad you know
with all the fad of cryptocurrency
there's been
no shortage of people just i mean
big connect was kind of the first pump
and dump pull the rug right
uh yeah it operated in a little bit of a
different manner than these modern ones
but um yeah it's kind of the uh the
archetype of um yeah i don't know
these influencers keep pushing these
like [ __ ] coins they call them and i
don't know why people invest in them
anymore because
like there's this one called save the
kids which is especially agree just
because
you know it's about saving the kids
apparently because they give one percent
to some charity
um save the kids it like couldn't be
better for a total [ __ ] to your scam
coney 2012 baby coney 20 top was that
guy scammer i think he was just a
uh maybe that wasn't a scam yeah yeah
yeah oh well maybe remember closer to
like
i don't know what exactly ryan cavanaugh
did but he did
apparently according to his ex-partner
written in variety brandon ponzi scheme
right which he accused him of in in open
court right understanding right
right yeah of course yeah i mean that's
how we know about it
anyway save the kids so let me tell you
it was promoted by
rice gum all the usual suspects the
entire fate not the entire
a many of the phase clan rice gum
can we call them a grilled cheese
grilled cheese sorry excuse me as my dad
said
grilled cheese and how this works is
basically they
go yo everybody there's this new crypto
save the kids that's going to the moon
i'm holding it for life and then they do
this big promotion
and then the minute that everybody
starts investing in this crypto they
sell all their shares the value plummets
and they're the only ones that make
money and everyone else will put money
in
uh loses horribly i mean that's a ponzi
scheme isn't it when you kick the can
well ponzi schemes i almost want to say
it's worse
because ponzi schemes usually are run
for an extended period of time hold on
show
uh brian cavanaugh go ahead dan
yeah he could probably explain it better
than i um
but alleged experience with ponzi
schemes um
yeah potter skins usually run for an
extended period of time you know like
bernie madoff
did it for years um whereas these
typically
you know they're in and out in a matter
of 24 hours once
once the coin hits the market so um
right i see is it is it different than a
ponzi scheme
yeah or well anyway so it's a scheme
it's basically theft where everyone puts
their money in this big pot and then
they take all the money
out and then say bye
so the big question is i mean here's the
promo video and i just love this you
know
here's the promo video for save the kids
coin
and it's your boy of course ricegum you
know big trust
there big trust save the kids my name's
frasier my name is jarvis i'm tico i'm
riceguard
i'm nikon and i support save the kids
token save the kids token
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids tokens
redistributing wealth into our pockets
from yours
you know i mean what the [ __ ] this is so
corny bro and something that wasn't uh
in the talk i don't think but i just
sent you a link i just want to point out
their logos similarity to the legitimate
charities save the children
yeah not save the kids it is here i'll
pull it up uh yeah so they saved the
children which is a huge reputable um
you know charity they basically just
inverted it
yeah it's so save the children they're
like no no no save the kids
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
this is i don't know how these people
don't go to jail i really don't well
this is a developing story so
maybe give it a couple there's so much
crime going on the internet lately
like there's been shady shitty people
but now it's just devolved into actual
crime um
can you imagine seeing this though
wanting to invest your money like what
my name's frasier my name is john hi
we're all the shittiest people on the
internet
and we support save the kids
so here is a promo tweet
bryce gum of course hey yo guys super
excited to be an ambassador for save the
kids
this is going to be one of the biggest
tokens ever
launches on june 5th okay this is the
guy who's really in deep [ __ ] which
we'll explain
i'm extremely i'm extremely excited to
announce that i'm an ambassador for a
project that is coming very soon
they want to donate over a million
dollars to charity in 30 days
they're going to be huge
anyway it's kind of all the same tweet
like obviously in reality
you guys got scammed and they're all in
phase
plus ricegum who's friends with all them
and so it's the same [ __ ] guys it's
all the shittiest people in the world
um you know at the time of launch
a hundred dollar well if you invested a
hundred dollars at the time of launch
three weeks ago
it would now be worth six dollars and
fifty cents
[Music]
which i'm surprised there's even that
much money left in that
surprises just it's not worth nothing
i take that six dollars out now if i
were you if you had money in there
get what you can so here here's where it
gets really shady
they all promoted it and there's this
thing
that is called an anti-whale
clause in the code which means this is a
screenshot from the guy who programmed
save the kids it means that you can't
sell more
or tr you can't sell or transfer a huge
amount of coins
and in in 24 hour period so if you sell
off a big amount you have to wait
another 24 hours
is to prevent what happened which is
what they call a roll
a rug pull where the value drops
immensely
immediately from everybody's selling
yeah yeah it was
specifically it was uh you couldn't sell
more than 20
of your coins every 24 hours so
theoretically
if you wanted to sell everything you
would have it would take five days
because you could only sell 20
at a time right and seven days a week
and that's good because
it gives people security that oh this
isn't a rug pull scam where
right the value is gonna drop i'll know
that something's up
right because this has happened enough
with a lot of these same people
um that you know people have started to
get a little bit more cautious so now
they're giving these promises it's like
hey this isn't one of those
and we promise you because look at the
code you you literally can't do this
so here is uh i'm talking about it here
this guy coffeezilla
did a whole big investigation into those
really good
hours before you sell again the new code
which changed at the last minute
changed this anti-whale to one minute
you must wait a minute before you sell
again
and this is the only change they changed
the token
just so they could pre-meditate this
whole thing
and almost remove the anti-whale
mechanism completely
they turn so what happened was right
before the launch
here is this the guy talking about right
here let me see this right before the
launch do you remember
all these in all these influencers got
on the phone with the developer
and said okay you know that anti-whale
thing that prevents everyone from
getting scammed
we need you to reduce that from 24 hours
to one minute
right before that what the [ __ ] that was
a rice gum laughs that was a race come
on
wow
[Laughter]
yeah and we should point out so again
this is from uh coffeezilla's uh video
which shout out to him his video was
really good and he he did
a whole breakdown of all of this and
yeah he got the programmer of this coin
on the phone the programmer claims
he's just a hired gun he just did what
the bosses told him to do
i don't know if i believe that or not
but just to give a disclaimer of like
who it is that's
making these allegations well what i
don't understand is this programmer says
hey i'm just doing what the boss has
told me to do
yet he got all these influencers who
would say oh i'm just a um
i'm just an ambassador right then why
why is he listening to the influencers
telling him you need to change the thing
that's preventing this from being a scam
to one minute thereby making it a scam
so why would he listen to these
influencers if they're not his bosses
it doesn't make sense and the fbi is
going to investigate yeah there's a lot
of finger pointing going on right now
but anyway here they are talking about
it
which influencers were telling you that
you need to basically speed up
the time that they can basically dump
more of their only
remember because he's on my screen i
know smith was in the group chat i don't
know if he was one of the main ones who
was like
actually messaging it but i know there
was a general consensus of them being
concerned so they weren't the ones
telling me to lower it
they were very concerned with and i was
just trying to explain this is good for
the product
like blah blah like 24 hours why do you
think they were concerned about that
well i mean obviously now probably
because they want to dump right away
another interesting moment yeah
obviously
so um this really gets interesting when
you look
specifically at the phase clan
and this guy k who was dumb enough
who used his crypto wallet now crypto
wall if you guys don't know
um everything is public with crypto
and if you use the same wallet like kate
did a giveaway with this crypto wallet
so people knew it was his wallet even
though wallets are anonymous
the thing that k messed up um that the
other phase guys didn't do
is that people knew oh who who's his
wallet
know that it's his wallet so while phase
k is tweeting out like yo
save the kids i'm in this for the long
run he is literally at the same time
selling all of his coins
um here is once again coffeezilla
if it feels like i'm belaboring this
point i am phase k
has consistently deceived his audience
by pushing crypto to them
while having a bag of crypto given to
him by these coins i guess for
promotions
and selling it immediately to them and
he'll make videos
promoting these tokens like moon portal
your
moon portal is out right now guys you
can swipe up and check it out
he'll also tweet about them like this he
said wow
moonportal.io making the robin hood of
crypto
great project and great team behind it
i'm with them
long term a hundred hmm that's that
that's interesting really and with the
long term 100 luckily we can check your
wallet to see what you
actually did it looks like you received
the funds
37 days and 18 hours ago or on may 22nd
and it looks like you sold the coin also
on may 22nd
so it looks like phase k you may not
understand
you could see 30 minutes later he sold
the coin
so like and he did this a number of
times
save the kids is just the one the latest
one and the one that
they're all getting busted on and
finally you know getting in
some comeuppance for what they've been
doing
it's been going on for months with all
these guys you know
all these phase guys are in on this [ __ ]
ricegum
it's like they all act like they don't
know what's going on but this is a scam
going on that they're all doing
perpetrating and they all thought they
were just making easy money but this is
illegal
faze clan was like oh we're kicking out
k
we're kicking out jarvis nikon tico all
those guys they saw
phase clan has absolutely no involvement
in our members activity in the crypto
space when we strongly condemn their
recent behavior
they just all that's right to do it
independently from each other
and the owner of the owner or one of the
owners face blanks
face blank definitely hasn't been
involved in any of this [ __ ]
i think he's [ __ ] stupid
he says i don't know if this is clear
but i had no involvement with save the
kids and neither did faze
people acted as individuals and did all
that [ __ ] on their own and have been
removed as a result
okay so thanks sure i guess he was
involved in faith and save the kids but
was he involved in
bank social i o whatever the [ __ ] that
is
here fat back track to phase blanks
promoting almost verbatim by the way
this same they all promoted the same
[ __ ] way ten thousand dollars
giving away ten thousand dollars one
lucky person
that retweets likes and follows banks
isn't that his name that must be a
coincidence
surely that's a coincidence that the
[ __ ] coin
that happens to have the same name as
him he's promoting but he had nothing to
do with it
he's just an ambassador he's just an
ambassador
this project i [ __ ] with heavily
and truly believe is the next one to pop
yeah i'm sure bank social i o is gonna
be the next one to pop
i think he's [ __ ] stupid ten thousand
dollar winner chosen at random in the
next 24 hours good luck you sexy [ __ ]
a bank social to the moon not financial
advice lol
i don't think that's gonna hold up in
court the fact that he put lol
it's like he's just acknowledging the
fact that it's [ __ ]
i'm infinitely smarter than you and um
infinitely more successful than you
i it's easier to be successful when
you're just stealing money from your kid
from your fans i mean
blank i don't know if i would call that
success though
i mean i'm not worried about the fbi
arresting me for fraud
maybe that's a different metrics of
success not being worried about the fbi
arresting you how many indictments
i have zero indictment right that's
where he's competing
yeah i mean if he has more indictments
for grand juries
then he's more successful probably
or he'll be very successful in the
coming years
uh so he tweeted out about this one
and uh the point of course that coin got
pumped and dumped immediately after he
sold it
the same [ __ ] well hold on just go ahead
i'm sure he's gonna see this eventually
and and
i need to be thanks he says that he
didn't sell
now the thing i'm about to read his
statement right but the point is
that he promoted it and then it it
crashed it crashed
everybody sold it right phase blanks of
course who promoted
bank social which dropped in all of its
value after being
launched uh had this to say about all of
his friends
and teammates on phase uh
allegedly scamming people with crypto
here he goes
the legend himself phase blinks
this guy is the trashiest human being
alive so epic dude i mean
the fact that this guy this is the
definition of dumb luck
i think he's [ __ ] stupid the fact
that this guy has
any level of success in this world while
simultaneously being
so dumb
is the very proof and definition of dumb
luck wow
what do you think about all the phase
members being kicked out of phase for
the whole thing that's
the decision whose car was hood was he
on was this some random dude
no i'm probably a buddy of his or
something i don't know i'm gonna sit on
the hood of your car bro
i'm [ __ ] celebrity bro i don't ever
take off my hat because i'm so ashamed
of why doesn't just get hair
plugs or something he's rich enough he's
got nice hair in the back of his head i
mean i would get her just
just shave that [ __ ] brother just own it
just do it be a man like damn
just [ __ ] own the dome let's [ __ ]
own that i respect that about you that
you own the dome dan
[ __ ] it you know dan please stand up
please stand up dan
dan please stand up own the dome bank
be a man be a man like dan
[Applause]
god knows you can afford it with all
those banks coins
how much you mud from that probably
honestly
hey all jokes decided this is a serious
matter
okay do you think there's a chance
they'll come back
can i ask you something why is it that
every douchebag in the world does this
they go
right you know what i'm talking about i
know exactly what you're talking about
i i don't know why he's doing that but
it's like
that's like the douchebag thing yeah
it's like the same dude that scratches
his nuts in front of company
yeah i think it's a way to like show off
your abs or something but he is not in
shape i mean i'm not one to speak but
i'm not out there trying to
flaunt my [ __ ] i mean but if you ever
see a guy doing this just remember i
said that there's a chance
to come back like where you can't itch
yourself over your shirt
[Music]
you know i don't know man it's like the
balls in their core you know what i'm
saying
okay like it's up to them what is that
yeah
he says we've kicked him out of phase it
was his decision
and it's up to them if they come back
the ball is in their court
i think he's [ __ ] stupid what does
that mean
phase blanks he keeps reiterating if you
continue the clip
over and over again he's like the ball's
in their corner it's up to them if they
want to come back it's like what that
sounds like bad management bro
or did they or did they not do something
bad i mean you kicked them out over this
so what does that mean it's up to them
i think faze blinks knows a little bit
more about what happened then he's
leading on
could be besides is there a chance they
would come back to the face
they can't say that all i can say is
like i said
everyone's looking for an explanation
everyone wants to know what's going on
those are my brothers
yeah but they also scammed people so
like man they're his brother
you know i used to it's like you might
have used to golf with oj
but like or like bill cosby but you know
at a certain point you gotta draw the
line somewhere
those are my brothers bro
okay i don't know man yeah those are my
brothers though like we'll see what they
gotta say
i don't know that's that's shirt hand
back in the shirt and back on the shirt
what do you think about the whole social
club uh thing that also happened
he thinks he's so [ __ ] cool
got a joint
if people see his bald ass dumb and not
that there's anything wrong with it but
he wouldn't look as cool i wish he would
just
let the dome breathe well he's got
full-on friar tuck hairs yeah like that
to the next level
um i i i
know um hassan whenever he's talking
about him calls him brother banks
you know from friar i i i yeah i'm not
sure if that's why he calls him
that's why people a lot of people call
brother banks because he's like got that
friar bald spot
the only time it's ever been actually
seen because he's always wearing a hat
is when he got in a fight in a bar right
and they released the security footage
phase banks
bald spot and um here
you can see just because the bar look at
this [ __ ]
and look hey it's a bad angle to be fair
but well
i mean obviously that as it may i mean
this was years ago too
listen i get it man it sucks to be
losing your hair but you either
like ethan said you got the money dude
like get the implants or or just [ __ ]
just shave that [ __ ] it's not a big deal
just don't be ashamed i'm saying i'm
saying
face banks you're a confident guy you're
so cool you walk with your shirt under
your shirt
under your you walk with your hand on
your shirt you're smoking joints you're
the coolest [ __ ] guy you're sitting
on hoods
it's just we got to keep the image
straight we we need to do something
about this bald spot
and there's nothing wrong with being
bald i mean looks it happens to people
i mean and this just advice for you
because you're such a cool dude and i
just think so highly of you and i want
you to maintain your perfect image
for example you can't be getting a
situation like this getting in fights
and then you know
the bar releasing the footage and then
you get this so that's not a good look
so we got to do something
that's my only point that's a fair point
this is the brother this is the brother
banks memes
[Laughter]
that's why his song calls him brother
banks
[Music]
oh people are so cruel faze bald i mean
come on guys
that's not that's not what this is about
look at this thumbnail bald i mean
people are just cruel
i mean look at this one that's from the
side pro that is a lot of baldness
my god and you know like i said i'm not
i just i just want the best for him so
that's not a big deal it happened
it's something like 60 or 70 percent of
men
he happens to you know yeah just roll
with it dude i think he's [ __ ] stupid
exactly just roll with it you got to own
it shave it off get some implants just i
want you to maintain your cool image
because if your hat falls off it just
ruins everything you've built
you know 50 53 of men
it's a logan paul's airline people are
so mean i shouldn't joke about baldus
because it's you know
i shouldn't do that it's just
it's funny when when people try
are obviously insecure about it and
try and hide it when it it's so obvious
what's going on that's why i'm just
saying like do what i did just [ __ ]
shave it
way better after i did that like you
look good with the dumb thank you i
think it's dignified
yeah you own it you got a good ass beard
bald dudes usually have good ass beards
too we love dan
it's the the great irony of life of
having hair where uh
where you don't need it yeah exactly
yeah face has a good beard too so
that's what i'm saying like yeah you
can't rock it he's got the tattoos too
like the tattoos helped as well like the
bald guy
tatted up big beard like this
he's a cool dude anyway phase blanks
ladies and gentlemen
um i'm gonna start a
phase hair transplant coin
say and one percent of it is going to go
to a charity
to pay for hair transplants for banks
it's a save the kids kind of thing
i hope to raise one million dollars by
the end of next month
anyway um god but you know these crypto
things been going on so long aiden ross
he's huge on twitch now
also friends with all those guys you've
seen him in videos with faceblinks
roommates with uh with grilled cheese
right grilled cheese and faze blanks
they all live together yes that's the
content house the [ __ ]
magillac and goddamn face blanks
magic dumped lana rhodes to live
with these [ __ ] frat boys
in his late 30s that's the thing that i
can't wrap my head around
well anyway aiden ross listen to this
[ __ ] dip [ __ ] i mean these kids have
no problem
scamming their fans it's
unbelievable by the way that milk token
[ __ ] i did a while back
i already told you guys don't buy that
[ __ ] i got paid a bag do that [ __ ]
like i don't give a [ __ ] how many guys
actually bought it
[Music]
[Laughter]
by the way that milf token there you go
jesus
i mean just straight up kind of a seth
rogen thing eh but more just more like
scammy it's like seth rogen on scam yeah
by the way that milf token [ __ ] i did
while back
i already told it's all these guys all
these usual suspects are just scamming
people
it's just a big coincidence that a giant
group of friends that are all in
business together
and all live together all are running
the exact same scam
but none of them know about it no no no
no no no no
phase didn't know another thing about
that is blank star anything about it
it just so happens the only guy it only
happens that the only guy
who knows anything about it is face k
the one whose wallet was accidentally
exposed so they could see he dumped it
right afterwards
right he's the only one that knows about
it to be clear the other two guys that
they suspended the jarvis
you know who's in all the crying memes
or whatever yeah he's the one that got
like banned from fortnite
right and for one of the other ones
another great guy so their wallets also
got exposed
which is why they also got in trouble
the only reason that they got in less
trouble is they
only dumped part of their coins they
didn't do like a full
blatant dump the way that kate did so
they they you know they sold like
30 of their coins and held on to the
rest which is still
bad but it's not as blatant and so they
they are
they are i believe just suspended
whereas the k guy
got completely love you're having way
too much fun back there
what is he doing love has got like the
um the soy eyes show the
eyes the soy eyes look at this
look dan
i love that [ __ ] is that a [ __ ]
filter
that's amazing that's the song
yeah i was about to say love is uh are
you disappointed in your face guys love
you probably are fans of them you're the
fans of everyone yeah i've been watching
them
since uh for a long time like probably
10 years
you think they went too far this time
yeah a little bit
i also thought they went too far when
they
allegedly owned a gambling site
csgo lotto right or cs go wild i think
it was
go wild yeah does it surprise you guys
that they were also involved in the cs
go gambling scheme allegedly they are
the phase owned cs go
wild yeah you're asking if we're
surprised by that
yeah are you surprised by that uh no
okay i am not actually surprised by that
i was going to say that clip of aiden
sounds almost like exactly like rice gum
did in the mystery box scandal in his
video they're like oh i just got the bag
yeah i got the bag i hope none of you
guys bought that [ __ ] though
yo for real well why'd you promote it to
your fans then dub
[ __ ] i gotta pay the back do that [ __ ]
like i don't give a [ __ ] how many guys
actually bought it
probably shouldn't have taken the money
then dude what's funny about
what's funny about intentionally
guiding your [ __ ] supporters
into a scam i don't find that funny
got the bag dude you think these guys
have are you are you
have they lost you as a fan uh love are
you still phase for life are you phasing
up
oh yeah they totally lost me interesting
oh wow
i lost quite a bit of money on that
gambling site as well when i was 16.
oh see that's case in point it's like
that's these are the people they don't
know better
tell me about your experience as a
six-year-old gambling on that because
i'm curious
i didn't know that well you know in
sweden we get some money for going to
school
when we're 16. we have about hundred
bucks a month what
yeah damn that's sick
and i saved that off so i had maybe
a thousand bucks and i bought csgo skins
for that
and i gambled them all away and so
you're 16 years old
you bought all these expensive skins
you're going on these gambling sites
and when you're winning skins is your
intention to
sell them and make money
well yeah yeah see that's interesting
it's like a
it's such a loophole the gambling they
found
yeah and um and how long did it take you
to lose all of your savings
um well i went up at first and um
i thought it was great and i did not
stop
just like that's that's the thing with
gambling you never stop and you
come here zack what the [ __ ]
so so you lost it all did you how did
you feel when you lost all you're like
very bad yeah and my grades dropped
you it affected your mental health yeah
oh yeah
mom yikes that's
probably the standard experience of
everybody that was involved in that you
know yes please
all my friends were doing this right so
thousands of dollars from the swedish
tax money just going straight to
facebook's walkie
allegedly you know at the time that
we did our cs go gambling um video on
on our main channel back in the day
there was like a multi-billion dollar
business the cs go gambling [ __ ]
yeah it's disappointing i i used to like
phase banks as well i wasn't too much
into
the other guys but i was like that he
was very open about mental health and
he seemed to have some kind of pity
towards others who were going through
things like
fousey2 when he was going through his
drama i was about to say
there was a point where i was like oh he
doesn't seem like that bad of a guy
i mean that whole fousey saga with keem
there was that video i mean listen like
ballistic and
banks was the only one that was like
dude this is [ __ ] up i mean next to
keemstar everyone looks like mother
teresa
right i guess that's really it's all
relative right so father banks
yeah brother banks yeah
well i know what you mean though i i
there was a point where i thought he was
a decent guy too but
when i look at everything faze is doing
and his he's at the
circle he's at the center of everything
there yeah
you know which website did you lose all
your money on love
uh cisco wild cisco lotto oh those were
all the
wrong oh yeah lotto was the one that was
owned by the guys i talked about
yep and then wild was the one that was
owned by faze members
allegedly allegedly yeah fantastic
and you know i'll add i think still it's
like a multi-million dollar
industry it's still up and running oh
yeah they they found some new poles to
get around the
that's crazy that's just so sad man just
gambling is such a [ __ ]
venomous act it's just such a toxic
poisonous activity
that that anytime kids have access to it
like on a
organized grand scale is just so bad
it's just so bad for their
mental health obviously they're going to
lose all their money it's just
it's a horrible because you know young
impressionable minds at 16 years old
your brain is still growing and maturing
and
that kind of stimulation has just got to
be super unhealthy
for sure blanks
well anyway save the kids token is
removed i mean
it's not online anymore it's just it's
just
it's gone i mean there's no pretense
about
bye bye yeah the uh in the coffeezilla
video again
um when he spoke to the developer the
developer says that everybody involved
in the project
blocked him like just like dipped
immediately blocked him on everything
and just disappeared into these here's
the website before it was taken down
rice gum right there in the middle baby
let's go
these are the guys who are giving their
name
you can't rice gum tries to say he just
was paid bro
you let them put a picture of you on
their [ __ ] website like hello that's
called
giving them credibility
well anyway um
you know oh by the way that
that milf token that aiden ross was
talking about got dumped immediately too
it was worth when when he promoted it it
was worth
point zero zero one cents today
it's worth point zero zero zero zero six
cents whatever that was big massive
dumps
also keemstar of course any good scam is
not
complete without the involvement of
keemstar covering this
some people put out a theory that save
the kids failed because of a tweet
keemstar is here running defense for his
friends covering up a scam
so quick to call literally anyone for
the smallest thing but when it comes to
his friend he's willing to pervert
and even and and in time straight up
even lie
uh distort the truth to to cover for his
friends that's why he is literally the
[ __ ] worst and it's just so happens
that his friends are all evil scumbags
too but here you go
from nelq that went out so they're
promoting it they're telling people that
they're ambassadors or whatever
the point comes uh zach
play that again keemstar shut up
i love that did we ever show that clip
i don't think we did i think we just
watched it behind this i think i gotta
show that for the contacts but this guy
screams at keemstar shut up [ __ ]
shut up [ __ ] and keemstar shuts his
mouth too
going up in value and then nelk puts out
this pose and after that tweet comes out
from nelk
everybody starts panic selling and the
save the kids coin
plummets down and everyone loses their
money okay so the idea here is that it's
all
of nelk's fault for calling out these
influencers
for what they're doing and it caused
this big panic cell it sounds
interesting but
it's completely false and i want to
debunk this because i think this was
likely told to keemstar
to just make these influencers seem like
they're innocent but
it's false i know this because we can
actually see
when the tweet went out 7 55 june 5th
and phase k actually started selling
before that tweet
as you can see here he first started
selling june 5th as well
but this is utc time and adjusting for
that he started selling in 605
which is about two hours before nelk
would tweet
nice try keemstar you scumbag piece of
[ __ ]
i mean keemstar is such a piece of [ __ ]
it like never [ __ ] ends bro
he's literally running defense for his
friends friends that scam people
the thing is people believe him they go
oh no it was nelk that tweeted that
caused the entire crypto
to bottom out
bro these people shut up
these people are just such scumbags and
i just want to say too that um
you know the save the kids thing is the
latest and it involved all these faze
people and so that's why we're
we're talking about them uh primarily
but
this whole trend is way wider than just
the faze clan
and some huge influencers up to the the
[ __ ] kardashians
uh have been involved in these sort of
rug poll now
you know the degree of their involvement
is is
unknown and they you know in most cases
they probably just got paid
uh without really understanding what
they were supporting but it
the the list is wild i actually i have a
partial list here oh give me that
yeah um this this was pulled from a
comment on reddit that i came across
of uh people that have done this uh
hafu ricegum aiden ross jake paul
tana monju summer rae keemstar
half of the faze clan uh karina kampf
and scotty sire from the vlog squad
scotty yeah little yachty kim kardashian
floyd mayweather
sam sam pepper deep cut in the h3 yeah
um
this one has a big asterisk and says
allegedly i don't know anything about
this but mr beast apparently was
involved in one of these at one point
and um and countless more um
it's just it it's getting completely mr
beast surprised me but everyone else on
that list
is like exactly the people i would
expect to be involved in this
no [ __ ] morals no care
just give me the money and [ __ ] everyone
right in reality
his is the only name that has a little
annotation that
that one's not i have a hard time i know
he's involved in crypto stuff but i
don't i mean he's rich as [ __ ] i don't
think he needs to be involved in
anything like i
i don't know the details i don't know
the details either here's one great
banger from keemstar
someone said weren't you scamming people
with crypto coins he said yes
well let me repeat that ladies and
gentlemen we got him
let me repeat that emma asked weren't
you scamming people with crypto
keemstar says yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we got him
maybe we should have keemstar's picture
up here instead of ryan kevin
that tweet that tweet is amazing i love
that
yes i publicly tweeted what i was into
and went and sold so if you didn't do
exactly what i was doing you got scammed
because i did very very well
i am not a financial advisor i am a
youtuber
clearly but just remember
were you scamming with people with
crypto coin yes
fantastic what a great guy and they're
all friends all these
look all these people know so you know
that's what's going on on youtube lately
we hate keemstar anyway listen um
speaking of crypto i myself
started dabbling because i see all these
people making tons of money
and i says you know hey i've got a lot
of fans and uh
they're probably all looking for
investment opportunities still and
true so i made my own coin
fupacoin and um here's how it went down
let's go ahead
uh hey ethan can i talk to you real
quick yeah of course what's up you're
looking very great
oh thank you so much you too and the
kids are doing good they are thank you
very much
why does my check say uh 100 billion
fupacoin you see take a look at that
yeah this is uh oh i didn't tell you
about so this is fupacoin
um i'm switching all you guys salary to
this new crypto that i've heard about
and
you know 100 billion i'm thinking
that's way more than like whatever i pay
you
by like 100 a month or something so
that's i mean that's pretty big number
what does that translate
to um i will have to check the markets
but
football coins going to the moon so okay
this is a good opportunity for i just
thought it was a good opportunity for
you guys to get on the bottom
the floor you know the the ground floor
of this great
it's i mean to the moon yeah all the way
to the moon
not the mariana trench i mean i have
like bills and
and stuff i yeah i doubt i don't think
she accepts this
because she doesn't accept football i
think my landlord's on that oh she
doesn't accept crypto
no i don't know what to do with this
ethan i don't think i can
posit this i i'm kind of shocked to be
honest dad
oh hey lovebot please am i am i getting
paid in
football what is this oh football coins
yeah i was just telling ian that it's uh
it's crypto it's 100 billion so it's
pretty good
so can i use this in normal stores and
stuff or
uh no not yet oh
no ethan this won't work i need to be
paid in usd
well i figured because it's
international and crypto is uh
bro yeah the [ __ ] is this are you
kidding me
yeah you told me about it i told you
this is completely [ __ ] legal you
can't pay me in pooper coin
yo i'm all about this [ __ ] man i'm
[ __ ] stoked dude like this
is a great somebody get it's ground
floor level that's 100 billion we're
going to the moon baby
bro coin to the moon dan you really want
you don't want this i i do not want this
i want us tender legal tender that's
that's what i'm paid in but this is a
new investment opportunity you're not
getting a point
please do you like own fupacoin did you
create
a coin oh no i'm a i'm what they call an
ambassador
i'm a football coin ambassador
you had to do all that research on phase
i thought it was so that we could talk
[ __ ] about that no i was doing
i was doing research now i'm just an
ambassador
i understand and i think this is [ __ ]
well dan why don't you give your check
the exact someone who i'll
gladly take that [ __ ] 100 billion 100
billion
a check you you own a coin that
ambassador thing that's not real
yes i own football clan god damn it what
the [ __ ]
hold on one sec guys now i hear you
i just think it's a really pancake swap
are you doing
i just think it's a really good
opportunity
hold on what's sex calm down bro you
wanted us to [ __ ] buy into this i got
a hundred billion
i just sold every i just sold out my
coin what i just made like
50 million dollars so can i sell mine
yeah but it's worth like 10 bucks now so
that's super coin
but but hold on to it zach because it's
gonna go up it's still going to the moon
right just because i sold 95
of it that i own okay it's gonna it'll
still go up it's a great opportunity
okay i trust you i'm still gonna hold on
to this oh yeah i'm calling the sec
yeah good luck with that dan yeah you
don't appreciate anything dude
football coin get out the [ __ ] out of
here doesn't want his 10 salary check
loser i'm rich bye
and that is a fairly accurate
representation a reenactment
of how crypto thank you
round of applause for the crew
yeah but hold on to that pupil coin
because um
even though i own 95 of all of them and
sold it
zach you're a good ian you're a good man
hold on to that it's a gir i believe i'm
in it for the long run
i'm i'm [ __ ] excited for this [ __ ]
man it's going to the moon baby
yeah i love zach's enthusiasm oh you
guys are haters
well um that was fantastic
you know it's so heavy duty but like
there's another crazy thing going i
can't i
almost like it's too heavy for me right
now let's do this um
there there's a crazy thing on twitch
where people are gambling
and they're being paid millions of
dollars to gamble illegally on twitch
it's like
on it's it's non-stop with this [ __ ] i
think we should do the compliment battle
because i'm like burned out on all these
schemers
you guys want to do that sure all right
we're gonna do the compliment battle
the game is that two of us will be
face to face here
you cannot break eye contact or laugh or
you lose
and you must complement each other
and the first one to break loses this is
going to be a tournament
of the champions right only saying the
nicest possible things about each other
right
because we love each other we do we did
that roast recently
and it just felt like we needed to kind
of purge
yeah i need that negative emotions i
need that yeah
i've heard enough about my tiny hands
last me a lifetime baby
you [ __ ] all right well we need to set
up for it so let's take it okay we'll be
right back
okay the compliment battle is ready
to begin and with me i have a hat a
magic hat
with six names in it folded in piece of
papers i will pick at random two names
the two competitors will stand before me
my name's in here too
and complement each other brutally
viciously
lovingly no looking away no laughing the
first to crack
loses the winner continues on
here we go the first two names
i've got two papers we have
lovebot excellent
versus zach let's go
okay all right let's set it up
contestants
step up to the camera lovebot versus
zach
okay here are our beautiful contestants
lovebot
uh with romantic music playing we've got
love hold or
sorry that's a b holding up the
microphone for love uh whenever you're
ready i'm going to go ahead
and say you guys take turns starting
with
love you're the first to compliment go
ahead love
okay so i'm taking this opportunity
to say that zach
i love i love every inch of you
that's very sweety thank you for the
nice compliment
i really like your blueness and you know
you're a little rough around the edges
because you're cracked screen but
you have a very pretty face love
i'm not gonna last in this i'm already
laughing
i come into work with lovebots and i see
your
back your car in the parking lot kind of
really brings a smile to my
face and it just brings me so much joy
to know you're in there
wow that's that's very sweety thank you
love butt your eyes just
pierce through my chest cavity
and just it's hard to breathe around you
yeah it was almost alive zach just
getting a warning i was breathing no
i know but you cracked this smile i
understand it wasn't allowed just a
warning
[Music]
when ethan drives gatsby in the office
and brings i just drive so fast that he
makes the wind in here
go crazy and your hair
flies up in the wind after him
my heart melts wow that's that's pretty
does have beautiful hair love that's a
good oh thank you i appreciate that
speaking of wind
i know we've never met in person you
know just be a robot but
i bet you have great smelling farts love
good wind quality fantastic one
is that true love do you have good wind
quality yes
i am from sweden what does that mean
people in sweden have nice smelling
farts
yes okay didn't know that the more you
know
love go ahead earlier in this
complement battle i did say i love every
inch of you
and you know that's not well that is
including your feet
which you guys at home can see on
ethan's feet.com
right now i do thank you i do have
fantastic feet they are pedicured
well hold on though he's not number one
on that site just to be clear
nowhere close
i love the fact that you look like a mix
between derek zoolander and hansel
and i always see you and i say that love
bot is so hot right now
hansel and zoolander we love that
fierce competitors true that's truly a
compliment oh
you're welcome and let me refer to the
audience at home again
i am a robot but i do have swelling
capabilities so i actually do smell
sack and you guys at home might not know
that his leather leather jackets smell
very good
leather jackets thank you
[Music]
he can smell through the bot that's
incredible incredible is absolutely
that is such a nice compliment you guys
are fierce competitors man
go ahead you know again going back to
the smell thing um
i bet you smell so good you smell like a
mix between
i'm speaking for love bot oil and
axe body spray and yes that aroma just
takes over me takes charge
i just want to say that about you i do
appreciate that
okay do we call a draw at this point
because these guys are i'm dying over
here
these guys are pretty good i think we
got to call a draw here let's let's give
it one more round one more round
all right love after you my friend try
and strike the killing blow now
starting with love
you know i'm not the tallest
so i do very much look up to many people
but i do look up the most to you sack
it's very sweet thank you you know i
uh i honestly i think you have a great
you have great facial hair and i wish i
was a lice
on your beard just so i could crawl
around
and just be inside you and you know go
in your nose hairs and
man it'd be a really good time
is there such thing as anal lice i
wonder are those crabs
i believe those are crabs so what's the
difference between crabs and
lice is just the genitals versus the
dome yeah i think so yeah they the crabs
just prefer the gents
crabs get a little crazy yeah the crabs
are gentlemen
yes anyways i would love to be a lice
you know
we we would have such a great time all
right guys
i'm calling to draw here you guys are
way too good at this wow
i'm gonna put you both in the winner's
bracket yeah yeah can you take him
but i gotta start i gotta go to two new
people now so this is the winners
bracket this is the losers bracket but
wow what a fantastic uh competition
thank you thank you
thank you you can't keep love on standby
here because he's
he's gonna be going again i'm impressed
man i can't believe what i just saw
a witness true competitors there was no
end in sight i had to put an end to that
yeah no good call
who's this by the way i forget the name
of this guy uh
uh unfortunately because we zoomed out
we don't have the zoom but for
from a distant it look right ryan ryan
kavanagh i believe my ex partner of
running a ponzi scheme right okay
right it looks like that was published
in variety one of the most respectable
trade papers in the entertainment
industry
there it is you can see it says we're
already yeah right okay up next go ahead
drum roll please
get ready ian
versus dan
we have our two switchers here in an
epic unexpected twist a b
is being forced to do some
improvisational editing here so if it
goes to [ __ ] you know who to blame
cancel a b i'm just kidding we love you
he's doing your best out here
ian versus dan i'm going to close my
eyes
who goes first dan you take the lead
you know the rules ian
something i've always loved about you is
that when i'm having a stressful day
and i am restless and i can't fall
asleep
i can just listen to your monotone drone
of your voice
and go on and on about the clippers or
whatever happens to interest you at that
time it's a little backhanded that's not
a compliment
monotone no it's it's beautiful why
would you say the sonorous
with the sonorous um the harmonic
quality of it
okay it's not as nice as the last battle
but yeah
okay wait hold on let dan finishes well
just
just listening to you speak it just i
feel like a little baby
in a in a carriage stripping away
beautiful okay all right i'll take it
what i absolutely adore about you
daniel it's word love is that
looking at you face to face right now
you are like the pokemon evolved
version of me
[Music]
the pokemon that's true he is the
pokemon of all versions i'm going to
write you to your uh pikachu yes
all right well i'm out because that was
good i don't blame you i laughed at that
i was [ __ ] so ian's going to the
winner's bracket dan is going to lose
bracket that was a quick one
that's kind of what i expected to happen
but these two the last one was so
fierce so fierce well the only two left
is me and you a b
okay ethan will be going first
a b yes as i stand before you today
i just look over you head to toe
and i just think you're so [ __ ] cool
dude thanks
your tats are sick as [ __ ] thanks dodge
and it's like
in arabic too which is spicy and cool
thank you
and [ __ ] got always clean j's on
clean jordans and i'm just like damn
this guy's got it all together
slim thank you
and the nicest thing i could say about
you is that you like me
thanks man i do i feel like there's like
six different things but okay
it's my turn i mean you know all right
okay these are adidas by the way but i
well you know i appreciate that you
compliment me even though you don't know
the name
they're jordans the colloquial terms
like your jays keep your js clean
thank you yeah i i love how generous you
are
and how kind you are the multiple raises
that you've given me
and just this year of working for you i
love
that you are a great person a great
father
great husband great boss
that's her fault i yeah i know i forgot
i'm trying to make you laugh i kind of
got lost in there
a little bit i'll take the sincere
compliments i need it okay
i love that after the rose you comforted
me even though you called me a shaky
[ __ ]
i did well i was a little bit of shaky
[ __ ] in a joking way sorry it was in
the episode it wasn't i think if i i was
just trying to be funny i felt it
because you said i have tiny hands yeah
i think you have large hands no you
don't massive
no they're not mastered don't come on
okay don't lie to me
all right you done i'm kind of yeah go
ahead okay thank you
thanks for the ab thank you so much for
the sincere
compliments
look me in the eye when i talk to you
okay
that that was a laugh i was about to go
with you said i'm a good dad and i was
gonna say something about that i'm your
dad i don't know
but okay we didn't get it
well thank you for the sincere uh kind
word baby that was beautiful so baby
was meaningful maybe he's going into the
loser bracket with me ethan that was
meaningful
going with the winners well since i'm
here let's just let me go up against one
of these freaks okay so i'll put uh
zach love and ian in the hat and we will
draw at random here we are and
we'll grab this one it's lovebot
such a fierce competitor i fear love
i fear this robot okay so
whenever you're ready oh i gotta pick
who goes first um
oh by the way before we uh it does say
uh
ryan kavanagh auntie scheme accused by
his partner
variety okay go ahead got it uh i drew
love
for going first so love take it away
go ahead when i was 16
as we earlier talked about i lost
a lot of gambling a lot of jackpots
and a lot of that stuff but
i could never imagine winning a jackpot
that ela did that
that is that she gets to be with you
every day
that is truly the biggest jackpot in
life that i can imagine
and banks doesn't have anything to do
with it
beautiful compliment wow yeah gorgeous
i'm touched
love you've heard of resting [ __ ] face
that's not you you have resting
zoolander face
and i mean that as the most sincere
compliment
possible thank you
i can imagine visiting you in sweden and
you're washing your car with gasoline
just like zoolander
and just turning quickly to everybody
like this
right he's eating snooze
and uh what's the tea time you do in
sweden
you doing you i bet you do the most
brutal freak
yes you have the most brutal magical
fleek
so i love that about you you're you
fleek
thank you you know
i'm not the most gifted human being in
english
so i just i think i'm just going to
break it loose
let's say say it in swedish
[Music]
you're not going to lose
[Music]
okay thank you love that's it and i'm
also going to do it in swedish for you
thank you speak
[Music]
[Laughter]
speaker
that's it that's it
yes last year when you hired me
i just couldn't imagine standing here
with you today
and i do think that's something that you
have
yes i
where's the mic what are you doing that
there where is the mic
oh here let well can you get okay yeah
you're good you're good
i think that's fine there you go sorry
to interrupt you what i was trying to
say
when i watched you on youtube back in
the days i i loved your content i loved
everything about you
but now i'm convinced
you are god wow thank you and i
and of course i'm happy someone finally
acknowledged that
love when i saw that buying you a robot
cost four thousand dollars so that you
could be here with us
i originally thought to myself that is
such a stupid
[ __ ] waste of money me too
what idiot what imbecile would actually
spend four thousand dollars on a [ __ ]
robot
that's such a bitter bitter waste of
money how much feed go would that buy
i could have speak over a whole decade
on that
but when i saw you satellited onto the
robot with
soy eyes
[Music]
yes um i thought to myself
not only is this the best purchase ever
[Music]
but now that ela is going out of town
i'm wondering would you accept the
invitation to live in the house with me
on the robot
yes as long as the wi-fi is good
the wi-fi i'll make sure it's good and
it's not that good let's be there it
kind of sucks over there actually
we'll make it work love overcomes
does love overcome love love overcomes
love
how can love overcome love love love is
infinite
yeah but how can love overcome love love
i can't answer that question
i don't know what it means i don't know
what love is i don't know what it means
what is love got to do with that baby
don't hurt me
okay i is this a draw i think it might
be another draw i mean i feel like this
could go over
that emotions yeah yeah it's kind of i'm
fit
it's kind of unfair to go and a robot
he's swedish and a robot
okay let me try something on you real
fast okay one last this is the last go
he's gonna kick me or something
well a b is behind you so hopefully not
love i just wanna complyment
your balance i've never met
once someone so bad
as you all right
the balance is just on look at the
balance
unbelievable i will laugh for 100 bucks
100 bucks i'll give you 100 bucks to
laugh dude
just [ __ ] left
love yes
stop it ethan this is cheating dude i'm
out i'm tapping out
you kind of laughed after that i'm out
okay this is [ __ ] i can't compete
against this yeah i don't want to
compete against it's tough
i'm forfeiting all right ethan is
forfeited
love is too powerful of a competitor as
a robot and a swedish man
all right this is gonna be an interest
this is gonna be a really good match up
zach
zack versus ian two classic crew members
are we still rolling though right two
classic crew members going way
back different with human interaction
like it's a completely different thing
that lovebot's hard man
that's hard oh yeah that lovebot is just
it's unbelievable
so here we have the i'm gonna do a
random pick here
see who goes first
uh zach you'll be going first okay
all right zach you're first go ahead
take it away
what are you doing what the [ __ ] was
that
zach let's let's let's re-roll what was
that
he did weird faces makes me laugh i'm
trying not to laugh here
okay okay restart
okay you know i sit next to you every
day
i don't know if anyone's ever told you
this but you have the most amazing teeth
smile you're just lights up around let's
see that's true i don't really smile
get the [ __ ] out of here how did you
hold it how did you hold up against love
for so long
i'm so different i'm a no i'm annoyed
because
i don't want to face that robot well
why'd you laugh he's not giving you much
much option here you want to give him
one more mull again
all right one more one more you want to
compliment me with that
well you didn't even make it through
your own turn you got to complete a turn
here zack
yeah i think you have the most amazing
style
you're my hype beast the definition of
hypebeast
is spelled i a n
wow that's pretty good thank you
we don't dress alike at all but
is that a compliment battles ian okay i
was just
you know making this observation no no
no no no
good what to say about zach
zach you are breaking
didn't say anything all right get out of
here zach
zach apparently is just i don't know
what happened here but zach goes to the
loser bracket
roll love out here for the grand
championship
yeah this is the battle this is the one
[Music]
i don't know how this one's gonna go
down this is gonna be
i don't know who to call this for
oh love the unlaughable
ian the uh incredible some people say
have said
ian is the funniest one on the crew do
you accept that
no because if it's true love might be in
trouble love's been getting some
some juicy lines out today yeah love is
on fire
so who do you guys think's gonna take
this one i mean i
i have faith in ian's comedy abilities
but i don't know this love characters i
just
i don't feel comfortable betting against
the swedish robot at all
yeah he's cold man but ian doesn't
really crack either
but it's this is different this is like
bobby fisher versus the computer
right who's bobby fisher which one's
bobby fisher
he's the chess guy so you're the
computer because there's
the computer oh you're bobby fisher well
that's complimentary to you
i'm the just champion yeah all right uh
go ahead love why don't you start off
yourself a little bit a little self-love
go ahead love
self love from love
so ian we all know
your hobby is suffering really really
good taste
in everything clothing
hairstyles beard slice
but i think
you would taste good
when he dropped out
hold on okay wait wait back up i you cut
out at you would taste good
well that was all i had to say
he's frozen he you would taste good ian
thank you like okay i'm not gonna unpack
that
[Music]
love what a word
if i could use one word it's your name
your frozen 240p
face still looks beautiful through the
pixels
look at it broken glass
you know you are absolutely frozen right
now but
your gaze stops me in my tracks too
brother yes thank you brother
i can't tell if he's laughing or not i
don't think he is we don't even know if
he's
smiling no i don't think so i go
don't keep piling him on my turn yes it
is love's turner
it's a love stern yes what
okay he's a lie what the [ __ ] is this
what the [ __ ] i've never seen love like
this before show love
but ian's out i gotta defend my boy ian
i think love is using the filter cam
just showed him
that's okay i feel like that's part
that's okay
damn he won he got him i mean ian draw i
mean i nobody can beat love
does anyone try to is the machine i
can't
he's alive it's uh john henry versus the
uh
steam drill yeah i mean you're right
you went postman
oh my god does anyone want to take a
crack at trying to get love to life no
no there's no hope and look he's [ __ ]
he's looking he's
cybernetically enhanced i can beat this
guy
go ahead ian if you anyone can do it
it's you make no i it's so you're out
so loves the champ we're just calling it
like that you you've you've defeated me
fair and square and because of that i
would like to give you 100 billion floop
a coin
oh my gosh he's crying
he's crying he's so thrilled that's the
grand prize actually i was going to give
the winner 100 billion [ __ ] oh well
he's got my share so
i i leave in defeat
[Applause]
[Music]
well i just don't have any feelings
that's all can i try one more time
okay i mean i tried for a good long time
i got nothing on this guy
that was fun though good job everyone
that was fun good times huh
well everyone thanks for watching this
has been
off the rails and we've been a little
off the rails today
not as off the rails as ryan kavanaugh
you know
allegedly alleged well we he may be on
the rails he may not be
there's a lot of allegations well being
off the rails is kind of like you know
right hard to say
but if i would say running a ponzi
scheme based on his ex-partner
allegations in open court were just
proved by the foreign
variety that's off the rails not as
off-the-rails as me i mean
also running you know so i but a lot of
fun
we'll be back on friday and uh
last after dark for a couple weeks
actually oh yeah ela's leaving
yes indeed and i said tomorrow well
we'll talk about it on friday but yeah
friday's our last off the rails for a
couple weeks
we'll talk about it on friday i gotta
run home and take care of my son
so until then
[Music]
you